simon is back on america's got talent
after breaking his back
and he told matt cohen just how scary it
really was
if you saw the scan i mean i was like a
millimeter away from just completely
cutting my back in half
weirdly it was a good thing that it
happened the whole therapy thing
you really really really have to
exercise more so
i feel better than i did a year ago
weirdly
it could have been a lot worse i was
very lucky after a six-hour spine
surgery and nine months of rehab
simon's looking super fit and believe it
or not he's back on his electric
bike he's also back on the agt set
through a physical therapy they're
forcing him to do at least ten thousand
steps a day how does it feel to have the
team back together
well i don't think lucky charm is too
pleased about it maybe not for you
i mean they blame me for everything that
happened last season because it was my
first season
yeah so you have to understand you're
talking about the the kova thing and
then all of a sudden heidi going down
and disappearing
simon goes down it was literally
a cornucopia of pain actually i might
have saved the season because he was
gone
you know i went like so you know they
play me for everything but i
i don't agree sophia makes heidi t
gets sick if beer buys me a bike i break
my back